It's been a few years since Disney's Frozen
burst onto the screen, so we wouldn't blame
you if you've let go some of the finer details
of the plot.
Fortunately, we've gathered together everything
you need to know before heading to the theater
for the sequel.
Originally conceived as a loose retelling
of the Hans Christian Andersen tale "The Snow
Queen," the initial vision for Frozen looked
a lot different than the movie Disney wound
up releasing.
In the original script, Elsa was an indisputable
villain, she and Anna weren't sisters or even
royalty, and the story culminated in a climactic
battle featuring an army of snow monsters
and a devastating avalanche.
However, director Chris Buck and writer, and
eventual co-director, Jennifer Lee realized
something was missing, and decided to make
its two central characters sisters instead
of strangers.
"Do you wanna build a snowman?"
The final piece of the Frozen puzzle fell
into place when songwriters Kristen Anderson-Lopez
and Robert Lopez wrote their first song that
would make it into the finished film, "Let
It Go."
After hearing the song, Lee and Buck realized
they couldn't keep Elsa a villain, and rewrote
the script in order to make her more of a
conflicted co-lead.
The final version of the film featured a pair
of sisters who loved each other dearly, but
were driven apart by Elsa's inability to control
her powers.
This change also required the filmmakers to
reimagine the character of Olaf from a villainous
henchman into a lovable, goofy sidekick.
C'mon…could you even imagine this guy getting
up to no good?
As evidenced by the original film's twisting
path to the screen, Frozen was a collaborative
effort between the writers, directors, and
songwriters, and wouldn't have come to exist
in its current form without any one of those
specific peoples' input.
Fortunately, the whole team is returning for
the sequel, albeit in slightly altered roles.
Chris Buck is back in the co-director's chair,
as is Jennifer Lee, who was also named head
of Walt Disney Animation Studios in 2018.
On the music front, songwriters Kristen Anderson-Lopez
and Robert Lopez are returning with 11 original
new songs for the soundtrack, and Christophe
Beck is coming back to compose the score.
The only significant difference in the creative
team between Frozen and Frozen 2 is the screenwriters.
While the original movie's script was penned
by co-director Jennifer Lee, she'll share
writing duties on the second film with Allison
Schroeder, who wrote the screenplay for 2018's
heartwarming Christopher Robin.
Schroeder was also nominated for an Oscar
for her screenplay for 2017's Hidden Figures,
making her a strong addition to the Frozen
team.
Frozen tells the tale of the two daughters
of the King and Queen of Arendelle: Elsa,
the elder sister, and Anna, the younger one.
Although the two were close as children, they
drifted apart after their parents taught Elsa
that the best way to deal with her magical
icy powers was to conceal them from the world
and to repress her emotions.
As a result, Elsa has isolated herself, and
only pulls further away when the King and
Queen are lost at sea.
However, as the oldest daughter, it's Elsa's
duty to take up the crown, but on the day
of her coronation, she loses control of her
powers and flees the kingdom.
Anna pursues her into the mountains, aided
by the ice harvester Kristoff and his trusty
reindeer Sven, hoping to convince Elsa to
end the sudden winter she's created in Arendelle.
Convinced she can't control her powers, Elsa
accidentally freezes Anna's heart, a spell
that will slowly kill her.
Dying and heartbroken, Anna returns to Arendelle,
where the sinister Hans is in the midst of
maneuvering to take control of the kingdom.
But before he can kill Elsa and seize the
crown, Anna stops him, and her act of true
love in saving her sister thaws her heart.
Realizing love is the key to controlling her
powers, Elsa ends the magical winter, reconciles
with Anna, and takes up her crown as Queen
of Arendelle.
Although six years will have passed for us
between Frozen and Frozen 2, according to
Disney's head of animation, Becky Bresee,
the story of Frozen 2 will begin three years
after the end of the first film.
Bresee told The Hollywood Reporter:
"It's an evolution and an expansion of the
story of Frozen, and many of the questions
raised in the first movie become the mysteries
that our gang are trying to solve in this
film."
She added that the main question of Frozen
2 will be, "Why was Elsa born with her powers?"
"Your power will only grow.
There is beauty in it, but also great danger."
But for anyone worried that Frozen 2's mystery-centered
storyline will be a departure from the first
film's focus on the relationship between two
sisters, you can put your fears to rest.
Disney's head of effects Marlon West assured
THR that the sequel is ultimately, quote,
"about two sisters trying to stay together
while the world tries to tear them apart."
That sounds like exactly what we'd hoped for
after the emotional, family-driven tale of
the first film.
Based on the trailers Disney has released
for Frozen 2, we can start to piece together
some of the plot.
In the beginning, all appears to be well in
Arendelle, with Queen Elsa ruling peacefully
over her subjects from her gently ice-frosted
castle.
But some sort of malevolent unseen force,
manifesting as pink flames, drives the Arendellians
out of their homes.
Determined to get to the bottom of what's
happened to them and fix it, Anna and Elsa
set off on a quest, accompanied by Kristoff,
Sven, and Olaf.
While the first film focused mostly on Anna,
Elsa looks to be the main protagonist of Frozen
2, as she attempts to track down the source
of a mysterious voice she hears calling to
her.
She hopes to discover the source of her powers,
and through that knowledge, somehow save her
kingdom.
The trailers also indicate that an enchanted
forest in the far north will prove to be significant
to the two sisters, and possibly provide some
further clues about the backstory of their
parents.
In discussing the story for Frozen 2, directors
Chris Buck and Jennifer Lee, together with
songwriters Kristen Anderson-Lopez and Robert
Lopez, realized they still had a few big lingering
questions after the events of the first film.
So they set about creating a story that would
answer them.
If the biggest question is indeed "why does
Elsa have her powers," then that leads to
a logical follow-up: "Why doesn't Anna have
powers?"
In digging into answers about the two sisters,
it becomes obvious that we really need to
know more about their parents, which calls
into question the circumstances surrounding
their deaths.
According to Lee, although the first film
implied that the King and Queen were headed
away on routine business when their ship sank,
things may not all be as they appear.
During the 2019 D23 Expo, Lee teased the question:
"Where were their parents really going when
that ship went down?"
We've been promised that the answers to all
these questions, and more, will be revealed
in Frozen 2.
Although audiences were introduced briefly
to King Agnarr and Queen Iduna at the beginning
of Frozen, they died very early on in the
film's narrative, and we learned almost nothing
about them.
At least, nothing beyond their instructions
to Elsa:
"Conceal it."
"Don't feel it."
Agnarr and Iduna weren't given names in the
first film, and had hardly any lines; for
their all-too-short presence, the queen was
voiced by co-director Jennifer Lee, with veteran
voice actor Maurice LaMarche as the king.
For their expanded roles in Frozen 2, however,
the royal couple will be voiced by Alfred
Molina and Evan Rachel Wood.
Judging by her two songs on the movie's soundtrack,
Iduna will have a particularly hefty role,
and according to Disney's press release, the
queen will begin to wonder if the answers
she seeks can be found in her own past.
The press release has less to say about Agnarr,
saying only that he'll do anything protect
his daughters from harm.
But the casting of the Golden Globe and Emmy-nominated
Molina makes it seem as though the king will
have a significant part to play as well.
Joining the impressive cast for Frozen 2,
which includes nearly every major player and
a few returning minor characters from the
first movie, is This is Us actor Sterling
K. Brown, who will be voicing Lieutenant Destin
Mattias.
An Arendelle soldier who's been trapped in
the Enchanted Forest for more than 30 years,
Lieutenant Mattias has, according to Disney's
press release,
"...never forgotten his sworn duty to Arendelle,
but the arrival of Queen Elsa and discovery
that she has magical powers is just the first
of many challenges to his long-held beliefs."
Lieutenant Mattias originally traveled to
the forest to fight against the nomadic Northuldra
people, presumably the enemies of Arendelle.
However, when we see him in the trailer, he
and his men appear to be standing alongside
the Northuldra, raising the question of whether
the animosity between the two groups was some
sort of misunderstanding, or whether the trailer
is simply working to mislead us.
A significant theme running through the first
Frozen was about first impressions being unreliable,
as evidenced with both Elsa and Hans, and
we wouldn't be surprised if it carries through
to the sequel in an even more prominent way.
Frozen may have had a compelling plot, but
the sequel will be broadening the scope of
the series' storytelling quite a bit.
Not only will Anna and Elsa be venturing far
outside the borders of Arendelle, but they'll
also be meeting new people who, at least at
first glance, appear very different from them.
Joining the cast of Frozen 2 are several members
of the Northuldra people, including their
leader, Yelana, the bold and brave Honeymaren,
and the eager, fun-loving Ryder.
According to Disney's press release, Yelana
is, "fiercely protective of her family and
community but is known to soften when people
show an understanding of nature and their
environment."
Meanwhile, Frozen 2's new pair of siblings,
Honeymaren and Ryder, seem to have views that
could put them at odds, with Honeymaren being
"a true free spirit [who] wants nothing more
than to bring peace to the Enchanted Forest,"
while Ryder "longs to embrace the world and
venture beyond the magical mist."
It'll be interesting to see how this brother
and sister pair plays against Arendelle's
royal sisters, and whether they'll all be
able to work together, or wind up butting
heads as only siblings can.
While the original film introduced us to such
non-human favorites as Olaf the snowman, Sven
the reindeer, and a colony of trolls, Frozen
2 looks to significantly expand its roster
of mystical, magical, and just plain adorable
creatures.
Nokk the water spirit can be seen in the trailer
as the watery horse that Elsa encounters in
the ocean.
Disney's press release states that Nokk is
"a fierce warrior and guards the secrets of
the forest fiercely," and that to get past
it, "a person must prove they are worthy and
earn its respect, an almost impossible task."
However, based on the brief shot of Elsa riding
the water stallion in the trailer, it appears
as though she manages to impress Nokk somehow.
Frozen 2 will also introduce us to Gale, a
playful wind spirit who can seemingly be seen
in the trailer tossing leaves and children
up into the air.
In addition, there are the massive stone earth
giants who we see in the trailer towering
over the treetops of the Enchanted Forest.
We'll also meet Bruni, a salamander who lives
in the Enchanted Forest who is fascinated
by Elsa's powerful ice magic.
After Elsa spent so much of the first movie
in isolation, it'll be nice to see her make
a tiny new friend in this one.
And if Josh Gad's tweets and Bruni's adorable
Japanese character poster are any indication,
when we finally meet Bruni on screen, we fully
expect to fall in love with the little guy
ourselves.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
Disney movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.